hey listen obviously we're here
celebrating comedy tonight uh and it is
netflix as a joke i want to get your
reaction to what happened with dave
chappelle this week what do you think
comedy community go from here do you
think well i i haven't i haven't seen it
so um but i hear that david's okay and
that's the most important thing yeah
you know what's funny i was thinking
about it again today and it's just
uncomfortable to not feel safe doing
your job man and like
not even even at least i said the least
he had security there you know i think
that goes with the award jimmy fox
come on like first of all you know if i
was backstage or chicago
no no i'm not joking but uh i just i
just want to feel safe going to all
these things man i think we really
it should be a lot of conversation about
security at that part because
the hollywood boat was a high stage he
had to have a running start
like nobody saw him
[Laughter]
triple m i would like a foot out of
something i just like i don't know it
was kind of crazy watching that video
it's crazy i know it's definitely kind
of like i said shaking the community so
hopefully they're putting in some
measures to keep you all safe
congratulations you've just been
kidnapped into the world's oldest and
most effective secret society of five
men lord lordington our highest ranking
member former australian media model
bruce baldwin ex-member of putin's
oligarchy michoud ivanov alice cooper's
former manager chef gordon and
what does it mean to be a part of a
project with mike myers mike myers is so
interested to me i did the gong show and
he stayed in character i don't know if
i've met mike myers i met the character
right and so this is really interesting
i mean really excited because like you
know as a comic as an actor
that's one of my favorite character uh
actors man he's a he's a beast i mean
he's playing eight different characters
in this one i counted
i wonder how you ever wonder how some
people is at home like him and eddie
murphy should have a character contest
that should be a versus they should do
it versus characters versus characters
that's what i'm talking about give me
one more chance did you get a front row
seat to all eight different mike myers
characters in this that's what i wanted
i did i i got i got a front row seat to
about five of them okay and then and
then one day i was just like i was
talking to another actor and i was like
you know everybody i got to tell you
mike's doing a great job
and it was mike
and it was mike wow color me embarrassed
so it was like
it really is incredible what he does
it's such a rare it's such a rare skill
that we see so few people do in
hollywood and this is a this is an old
you know an old tradition that we don't
see much elon cheney and peter sellers
eddie murphy and mike is part of that
really great tradition and it's i just
got chills thinking about it now you're
part of one yeah exactly i know it was
really great it's like when you say
there's five guys running the world
mike's four of them and i'm one yeah
he's four of them he's four of them
right yeah both beyonce and jay's said
are part of it sadly that's what
lemonade is about
yes the tent ever obviously is a secret
society of some influential people so if
you had to put your own secret society
with you and some celebs who would be on
there and why
i already got one i'm joking no i'm like
who's there who's in it well you know
what's funny i think about my group
texts like the golden lords which
consists of michael che
the lucas brothers me
jermaine fowler
sam j
quinta
i guess that is a secret society that is
y'all are doing big things in this
society i love it it's very important i
just exposed our group text to everybody
yeah how lit is that group text it's
really funny like it's really i hope
nobody ever steals our phones and
they'll kick all of us out of hollywood
well that's less than kind
and impossible i want to know who would
be in your pinterest like what celebs
would be in your secret society i would
be in my pen pentavra you think i've
been thinking about this for a long time
now can i say anybody like anybody okay
so like
here's who would be cool to be an
example i think of mother teresa and
jimi hendrix oh stephen hawking
tennessee williams the writer and then
walter payton you know i mean like
because you want to mix it up you want
to mix it up you want people from all
different parts of life in the penn
tabrt so you're getting different angles
of thought you know dare parties at your
house or something else huh
any of those names right
you